you know they say Hollywood has more
beautiful women the rest of the country
put together I don't know too much about
the rest of the country but it's a
pleasure to see how some of them around
here put together I can't think of two
better examples and the two girls about
to make the awards for art decoration
and set decoration from my left
miss Barbara Hale
and from my right miss Ruth Roman
thanks to those nice words mr. Douglas
you know I'm afraid to say that everyone
who comes on this stage let me say it
about John London I would have well
that's what makes horse racing Barbara
will you start off with the nominees
please
those nominated for the best achievement
in art direction of a black-and-white
picture are come to the stables 20th
Century Fox
Lyle wheeler and Joseph see right set
decoration Tom little and Paul is Fox
the air is paramount
Harry Horner and John beam had set
direction at a meal curry and madame
bovary veteran Goldwyn Mayer Cedric
Gibbons and Jack Martin Smith set
Direction Edwin B Willis I believe is
and Richard pepper Lee and now for the
unbroke Harry Horner and down the in for
the error
John me and a mercury this by the way
award in as much as in each case the our
decoration part direction and the septic
now the plaque is being handed or set
decoration and the Oscar of course for
art direction
those nominated for best achievement in
the art direction of a comic production
our adventures of John Warren Warner
Brothers edward career set Direction
line Ryan Schneider Little Women
metro-goldwyn-mayer Cedric Gibbons and
powered rose set Direction Edwin B
Willis and Jack D Moore and saraband J
Arthur rank Eagle Eye and British Jim
Monahan make Michael Ralph and William
Keller the envelopes please mr. whole
Court Cedric Gibbons and Paul Garcia
Little Women
design Richard a Peverley will accept
the awards for set decoration
set direction by Edward B Willis and
Jack D Moore
we have given away so many plaques
ladies and gentlemen and various and
sundry things and I might apologetically
say that the presence of Miss Hale and
Miss Roman is not conducive to sticking
to the script